[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire qu'est ce qui a changé dans
la consommation des français depuis le
début de la crise du corps d'un virus je
reçois dans cette émission michel
edouard leclerc qui publient les
essentiels de la république aux édition
de l'observatoire
on va revenir sur un certain nombre de
polémiques qui se sont déchaînés depuis
un an
mais d'abord une image tel que vous avez
choisie pour illustrer ce début du 21ème
siècle
michel edouard leclerc cette image là
voici alors pourquoi qu'est ce qu'elle
représente pour vous ben c'est un peu
une image caricaturale et en vain en
hyper réaliste ce ne sont pas les robots
d'amazones que l'on voit dans les rues
ce ne sont pas les drones
ce sont des des vélocipèdes east
d'hubert de des libéraux voilà c'est une
phase non cachée de la société digital
celle qui nous rend service mais qui
aussi rabat les cartes sur le marché du
travail qui ramène la régulation de
l'état dans l'entreprise dans qu'irène
qui les interpellent en matière de droit
social
voilà c'est notre l'extension de notre
liberté avec le digital repose la
question aussi du vivre ensemble et qui
travaille pour qui est bien commençons
[Musique]
michel edouard leclerc votre livre vient
de paraître aux éditions de
l'observatoire vous l'avez coécrit avec
alexandre tu à lyon il s'intitule les
essentiels de la république il est sous
titré comment la cabine 19 à changes et
la consommation des français
mais c'est aussi et peut-être surtout le
regard que l'on porte sur le commerce et
les commerçants qui a changé j'ai
l'impression n'ont jamais été très bien
vu dans notre pays on n'aime pas
beaucoup les marchands leur préfèrent
des agriculteurs les ouvriers les
fonctionnaires les militaires
et là tout à coup ils se sont retrouvés
en première ligne on les a reconsidéré
en tout cas on les a considérées d'un
autre oeil l'elysée même invité des
caissières assister au défilé du 14
juillet sur les champs elysées ça a dû
vous faire plaisir
oui j'ai toujours vécu ça à la fois une
une rencontre populaire les magasins les
marchés sont tout le monde est à vis de
ça d'ailleurs dès que les magasins sont
fermés on réclame la réouverture on se
précipite et quand on annonce qu'il va y
avoir des confinement on se précipite
chez arraché leclerc chez biocoop sur
les marchés il ya un rapport ambigu il
est le commerce et dans notre proximité
immédiate c'est un lieu de vie
peut-être par défaut d'autres lieux de
vie sains et en tout cas c'est un lieu
qui façonnent le lien social
et puis en même temps on a des élites
qui en france traditionnellement depuis
le xviiie siècle parle de commerce mais
en même temps ils sont comme on dit très
physiocrates quoi c'est l'industrie qui
créent de la valeur c'est l'agriculture
et la terre celui qui exploite la terre
qui créent de la valeur
le commerce aux yeux de beaucoup restent
parasites quoi ces visages et vécu ça en
quarante ans de métier et un peu plus de
soixante ans de vie aux côtés de mes
parents alors il faut il faut bien
réaliser que pour vous le choc a été
terrible en mars dernier quand on ferme
subitement les cantines et les
restaurants ce qui n'était jamais arrivé
cela signifie
millions de repas supplémentaires à la
maison c'est ce que vous écrivez dans
votre livre
forcément les achats en magasin explose
est-ce que l'on peut redouter ce sont
les pénuries et le rationnement or on
les a pas connu ouais voilà pendant
cette année qui vient de s'écouler on
peut dire quand même que les la
distribution le commerce français dans
toutes ses formes à approvisionner les
français il n'y a pas eu de crise de
l'approvisionnement mais mais c'est vrai
que de la manière dont c'est arrivé
c'était complètement inédit d'abord à
président de la république un premier
ministre qui annonce que des magasins
vont fermer qu' il va se passer des
trucs ils sont pas trop précis d'une
part nos salariés les salariés du
commerce ou les petits patrons ils ont
trois jours pour pour y faire face soit
pour fermer soit pour préparer un
affluent et les consommateurs pourtant
ils n'ont pas connu la moitié de la
population française n'a pas connu la
guerre
même pas les privations de la guerre
d'algérie et tout le monde se précipite
tout le monde achète des packs tout le
monde achète du pq tout le monde achète
c'est une séquence où elles détiennent
en quelque sorte sauf que on va pas
principalement vers la vodka ou le
whisky
on va vers des des usages de
conservation à incroyable vous pouvez
pas vous imaginer les quantités de patte
de conserves qu'on a qui ont été
échangés et alors évidemment ça perturbe
tous les flux de réapprovisionnement
d'autant que au moment où le confinement
au mois de mars de l'année dernière se
met en place
aussi les camionneurs ont des problèmes
de pour trouver des chauffeurs il ya de
l'absentéisme c'est tout les toute la
société française qui doit se réguler et
pendant qu'à la télévision on on annonce
des mesures
en fait ce sont des gens de terrain qui
sont sur le carrelage des hypermarchés
qui sont sur les marchés qui sont à
rungis qui sont à la sortie de la ferme
ou dans les abattoirs
c'est tous ces gens qui doivent
apprendre à se parler à se parler
d'abord au téléphone puis découvre les
vertus du whatsapp du télégramme
c'est une révolution on s'en rend pas
compte et ans
une semaine en une semaine les gens que
je côtoie et dont j'ai chroniqué la vie
où j'ai essayé de communiquer la vie ces
gens depuis l'ailé les hôtesses de
caisse jusqu'au aux manipulateurs de
marchandises dans les magasins ils vont
trouver leurs marques et une semaine
après le début du confinement le
ministère de la santé n'a plus qu'à à
gré leur protocole sanitaire
c'est assez exceptionnel comme capacité
d'adaptation
j'en ai j'en suis encore époustouflé et
moi c'est ce qui m'a surtout fait signer
je dois dire c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu de
rupture de stock réel
évidemment qu'on a vu les images de deux
rayons de supermarchés vide pour le
disiez pour le pour le papier toilette
les pâtes le riz le lait surgelé aussi
vous l'avez vécu mais au fond ça a été
vraiment anecdotique c'est à dire que
tout à coup les gens se mettent à manger
chez eux au lieu de manger au restaurant
ou dans les cantines et ils mangent dont
il achète dont beaucoup plus et ça tient
ça tient il faut pas l'oublier que les
importations sont arrêtés c'est à dire
que on va acheter que français il ya du
stock étrangers au début mais après
c'est que français au mois de mars il ya
en a l'habitude de manger de la fraise
espagnole du fruit de saison qui vient
d'italie ou d'espagne là non il est plus
gastel n'est pas encore en ligne dit le
périgord et donc il ya des tensions il
ya des tensions sur les produits à des
tensions sur les marques mais
globalement tout le monde a à bouffer
tout le monde a à manger quand on
certains se sont plaintes que les prix
avaient augmenté
c'est lié à ça c'est parce que tout à
coup on n'a plus les fraises d'espagne
web globalement il n'y a pas eu d'un
flash mob allemand chacun a l'impression
d'avoir payé plus cher
en fait la seule vraie inflation c'est
celle des produits agricoles français
que tout le monde a voulu acheter avant
saison c'est-à-dire là où c'est le plus
cher
la hausse est elle plus rares et en plus
la météo avait été très défavorable pour
nos produits agricoles et donc il ya eu
quand même pas mal de ça a beaucoup râlé
sur les produits sur le prix des
produits agricoles
néanmoins tout a été écoulée il n'y a
pas eu un transfert complet de la
restauration hors foyer vers la grande
distribution
d'autant que pareille de marché forain a
été fermée aussi mais quand même il n'y
a pas eu
l'inflation sur un an est n'excède pas
1% donc on n'est pas du tout dans la
spéculation n'est pas dans dans dans les
profiteurs de la crise quoi il ya eu une
rencontre coup il ya eu pour expliquer
tout ça il ya eu des ruptures de chaîne
d'approvisionnement on est passé de
l'avion au camion ou du bateau à l'avion
ça c'était très compliqué c'est surtout
sur la sphère des masques ce qu' il ya
eu beaucoup d'inflation sur l'a6 sur les
denrées en général les grandes enseignes
que ce soit carrefour auchan tout ça
tout le monde à bloquer les prix
s'étaient on savait nous commerçants
qu'on allait être accusé de sa d'être
des profiteurs de la crise et donc
toutes les enseignes ont bloqué leurs
prix alors justement parlons de la
bataille des masques puisque vous avez
été en première ligne de la bataille des
masques la grande distribution il faut
se souvenir que donc on n'a pas de
masque à l'époque que vous salariés en
réclame parce que les caissiers les
caissières qui sont en contact des
clients
ils veulent avoir des masques vous fait
un rapide calcul dans votre livre vous
dites qu'il vous en faudrait trois cent
soixante mille par jour
à un moment où il y en a pas un moment
où en fait il ya la guerre des masques
c'est à dire que chacun essaye d'acheter
des masques sur le marché mais au départ
on veut pas que vous en achetez voulait
la grande distribution c'est l'état qui
doit le faire à votre place
résumé nous la guerre des masses que tel
que vous l'avez vécu vous michel-edouard
leclerc
il ya plusieurs époques
ça vaut un film c'est des scénarios avec
des révélations de caractère
extraordinaire il ya d'abord un premier
scénario qui est à la fois raisonnable
ses priorités des masques pour le
personnel soignant mais il ya aussi
beaucoup de corporatisme
il ya il ya les groupements de
pharmaciens les médecins veulent être
prioritaire aussi pour pour pouvoir en
être et donc les mêmes syndicats qui
dans nos magasins réclament des masques
pour les caissières
quand ils deviennent syndicats de
l'hôpital il demande à ce qu'on nous les
pics pour les ramener à l'hôpital donc
c'est vraiment c'est kafka reims et
c'est enfin c'est peut-être pas kafka
mais c'est dû en fait on n'y comprend
rien ou alors on a dans les stocks
à ce moment là dans les chais des
industriels chez dassault chez peugeot
chez chez danone chez l'oréal on a des
masques qui nous sont restés des stocks
stratégiques on vérifie les élastiques
et tout ça mais on se rend compte que ça
va pas durer
et donc on prévient bruno le maire que
il va falloir que on a eu les chercher
et qu'on aille les chercher avec les
dents ou plus exactement au loup en des
avions avec des traders et bruno le
maire nous répond et moi je suis pas en
charge des masques ça c'est le secteur
de la santé et donc voilà il ya des
chefs d'entreprise qui veulent prendre
en main leurs responsabilités fournir
des masques à leur personnel souvenirs
les masques consommateurs et pourquoi
pas aussi en offrir à l'hôpital mais
pour le moment c'est interdit et donc
c'est un débat entre olivier véran les
équipes d'olivier verront peut-être le
premier ministre et puis de l'autre côté
bruno le maire qui a été je dois dire
impeccable et pragmatique dans cette
histoire et qui à un moment donné
ouvrant la deuxième phase nous a rappelé
qu' on serait jugé sur notre capacité
non pas appliquer ce que nous dit l'état
mais
à faire ce qu'il faut pour la sécurité
de nos salariés et des consommateurs et
donc quand on a eu le feu vert
quand on a eu le feu vert pour aller
chercher des masques on l'a oublié
on nous a dit n'achetez pas en france
plein de gens qui nous engueuler parce
que c'était pas les masques français
mais en fait dans la réalité les
filières françaises étaient réservées
pour les hôpitaux pour le personnel de
santé et même à l'international quand il
y avait des des grands fournisseurs
chinois
il était pré-sélectionné pour pour les
appels d'offres de l'état
elle dort je sais même pas mais en tout
cas pour l'état et du coup il a fallu
construire nos propres filières et là
moi qui vivais à côté de cette
opérationnel de crise j'ai vu l'effort
que des salariés des cadres qui n'y
connaissaient rien qui parlait pas un
chinois courant ou un russe courant
appelé le monde entier pour sourcer des
fournisseurs pour affréter des avions et
avec sans savoir si vraiment on n'allait
pas nous les piquets à l'arrivée et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui est arrivé
plusieurs fois c'est vrai que ça on s'en
souvient sur le tarmac même on avait
parfois l'état qui intervenait qui
réquisitionnait des masques prévu pour
telle ou telle région ou pour tel ou tel
grand distributeur à la suite de quoi il
va y avoir un véritable drame chevauché
par des théories du complot puisque à la
fin il ya la question du prix des
masques ayez le soupçon que vous avez
fait des stocks secret 1 la grande
distribution et vous nous vendez les
masques trop cher alors c'est ça que je
raconte en mettant des noms sur les sur
les accusateurs je me rappelle monsieur
muselier qui est le patron de la région
qu'à chacun paca qui à force de
gestuelle de faux doute exprimé à la
télévision je sais je sais pas il ya des
stocks cachés
il ya le président du syndicat des
pharmaciens il ya des médecins qui se
liguent pour dire que dans la réalité
nous on avait surtout peur parce qu'on
n'en avait pas on n'en avait pas on
avait passé commande
on s'était fait piquer
nos avions rappelez vous un moment donné
enfin 30 d'abord et il s'en foutait des
masses qui l'emportait pas et puis tout
d'un coup il a changé de politique et il
a rameuté tous les traders de la terre
c'est bien que toutes les cargaisons
qu'on avait en plus bien négocié la
leclerc prix prix pas trop cher et où on
se les ai fait rafler via ses traders
américains ou saoudiens et donc on nous
faisait procès d'avoir des masques dès
l'arrivée du premier avion est dans la
réalité il a fallu ramer ramer beaucoup
j'avais j'avais pas vu le poids des
fakes news et le poids de comme ça de la
délation il a fallu une commission d'
enquête sénatoriale pour rétablir
qu'effectivement la distribution a été
très efficace pour pour acheter des
masques pour les français bien que
leclerc on en a acheté 700 millions 1
depuis le début et c'est énorme
vous imaginez le nombre d'avions que ça
représentait tout ça aujourd'hui ça
vient par bateau mais on les a acheté
très cher alors non seulement on était
accusé d'avoir fait des stocks
non seulement on était accusé de les
avoir achetés d'ailleurs je sais pas
pour qui puisque c'était pas non plus
pour nos salariés mais en plus tout
cette surenchère rendrait rendait très
difficile notre approvisionnement
quand vous pensez que au coeur de la
crise certains vendaient le masque 10
euros alors qu'aujourd'hui je crois
qu'on le vend à 99 le paquet de 50
vous voyez le yo yo yo quoi est-ce que
ça vous est ce que vous avez gagné de
l'argent sur les masques est-ce que
c'était ça les grandes questions non non
non non non vous voyez rien que par
principe au début de la crise quand se
met en place dans les centres leclerc
une cellule de crise et c'est la même
chose à la fnac c'est la même chose chez
carrefour ou ou chez système u ou
intermarché
on sait on sait qu'on va devoir subir
toutes ces accusations
donc on a à côté de nouveau des
chroniqueurs et en l'occurrence j'étais
l'un d'eux de tout ce qu'on dirait de
nous et donc on prend les devants et par
exemple les masses c'est moi qui l'ait
dit sur les réseaux sociaux les leclerc
vont les vendre à prix coûtant comme ça
quel que soit le prix on peut faire la
démonstration qui a pas de marche dessus
et d'ailleurs on
ggd gd gagner ça très très vite et je me
suis pas rendu compte que pour un
pharmacien ça pouvait être un gagne pain
et du coup je m'en suis pris une bonne
rasade de critiques
on n'a pas été copains pendant toute
cette période là ils se rendent même pas
compte les pharmaciens qui nous attaque
est que nous avons des pharmaciens aussi
des diplômés de pharmacies qui nous
aidaient évidemment dans la
qualification des masques dans le
contrôle de toute la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
ouais c'était c'était sous x et la
grande histoire ne retiendra pas
l'agilité avec laquelle tous ces
personnes qui n'étaient pas préparés à
la gestion de crise qui avait
probablement que moi lui énormément de
livres de science fiction où on parlait
de contagion de pandémie et tout ça en
fait on n'a même pas appliquer ce qu'on
avait lu vous voyez ça ça c'est une des
leçons de la crise quoi la fiction ne
dit pas la réalité future ça c'est
philip k dick a pu abus a pu avoir tout
écrit je mens et moi j'ai tout lu de lui
ben vous voyez ce n'est pas ça va pas
servir tout de suite mais parce que la
réalité à un moment elle est devenue une
fiction
une fiction dont on n'avait jamais eu
l'idée par exemple je me souviens et
vous le raconter aussi dans votre livre
le moment où tout à coup des gens
arrivent au supermarché et on leur
demande de laisser leurs enfants dehors
un moment absolument invraisemblable on
est là on vient avec son petit enfant et
on me dit non non le petit enfant ne
rentre pas à tel point qu'ils avaient
eux mêmes des rumeurs comme quoi en fait
les enfants étaient trop importants de
la maladie etc etc
en fait vous le vous le rappeler un
moment on se dit bah attention il faut
il faut réguler l'entrée dans les
supermarchés et le gouvernement décide
qu'on ne peut rentrer qu'à 1 par chariot
une personne par chariot est la puce et
c'est ce qui va donner ces scènes
ahurissantes on voit des enfants restés
dehors alors ce qui est ce qu'il faut
voir c'est qu'il y en a eu très peu des
scènes comme ça mais elles vont courir
sur le net
et elles vont elles vont faire la
réputation à la fois de la mauvaise
réputation à la fois des vigiles qui ont
appliqué à la lettre cette police tu
peux dire mais aussi des magasins qui
savait plus trop comment se conformer
faut voir aussi que c'était à ce moment
là en plein confinement le magasin c'est
c'est le lieu de destination sociale
pratiquement unique quoi puisque on ne
peut se déplacer pendant une heure que
pour faire ses courses et donc c'est
vrai que les familles sont tentés de
venir au magasin même pas pour acheter
juste juste pour s'oxygéner pour et
voilà ce moment là a été assez difficile
à gérer notamment pour le personnel de
magasins et alors le c'est là où ou les
réseaux sociaux fin vous savez que je
suis assez présents sur les réseaux
sociaux je n'imaginais pas comment
quelques images quelquefois de même pas
prises en france dans un magasin ça fait
le tour de la planète et du coup la fecq
nous devient acte d'accusation c'est là
aussi il faudra il faudra décrypter tout
ce qui s'est dit on a vu il ya des
images qui sont passées en boucle dans
un magasin carrefour qui n'était même
pas un magasin français vous voyez et on
l'a attribué à la chaîne comme ça en
fait je crois que tu es un carrefour à
monaco qui avait qui étaient pas sous la
même réglementation mais il ya personne
pour contrebalancer ces images ou les
interpréter puis toute façon dans le
timing
vous pouvez rien faire c'est la vague
alors souvient qu'il ya une bonne partie
des français qui se retrouvent à soi on
leur en télétravail mais pas dans la
grande distribution
ils doivent venir travailler pour qu'on
puisse continuer de se nourrir et la
question évidemment que se pose votre
personnel c'est qu'est ce qu'on risque
elle ce qu'on risque sa vie en allant
travailler
c'est une question qui va hanter pendant
tout le premier confinement 1 et et un
moment bruno le maire
va proposer mille euros de prime à vos
salariés tous les salariés de la grande
distribution
il n'est pas venu vous posez la question
avant je pense alors avoir raconté que
vous déjà dans la grande distribution
en tout cas en deuil dans les centres
edouard leclerc il ya déjà 25 % des
bénéfices avant impôts qui sont qui sont
données au personnel ce qui fait à peu
près entre deux et trois mois de salaire
en plus mais les bonnes années a
forcément là c'était pas forcément une
bonne année comment vous êtes retrouvés
alors d'abord est ce que vous avez
manqué de personnel et et qui est est ce
que vous avez verser la prime de 1000
euros
alors on n'a pas manqué de personnel il
yat sen théisme dans des clusters
régionaux particulièrement dans son
alsace par exemple ou au nord de paris
mais globalement nos salariés étaient à
poste et il faut bien vous dire aussi
que dans la moitié de la france il n'y
avait pas ou peu de covin koala même si
l'acte sur la carte c'était rouge
on se demandait comment en vue de
bretagne ou vu des landes
on se demandait si c'était un truc de
parisiens ou parent ça a mis longtemps
avant de s'imprégner on avait à
l'internât gérer ça après oui comme nous
nous avions décidé d'affecter 25% des
résultats au personnel la proposition de
bruno le maire faisait sens pour les
pour les entreprises qui qui ne faisait
pas d'intéressement et de participation
mais noël sûr on savait pas trop si elle
sur ajouté si un peu si vous la donner à
certains ça vient diminuer le profit
distribuable aux autres c'était très
complexe quoi donc globalement sur cette
année là sur l'année dernière on a donné
le lait de et dans l'ensemble je pense
que tout le monde s'y retrouver il y
avait quelque chose aussi qui était très
malsain qui était pas clair c'est que je
pense que bruno le maire était bien
intentionnés ou le président de la
république mais ça faisait un peu le
salaire de la peur et pour le salaire de
la peur 1000 euros c'était pas cher et
donc il y avait une difficulté à à dire
on va donner 1000 euros au personnel le
plus exposé à celui qui est en danger
c'était à un moment où l'on refusait de
qualifier le coc vide de maladies
professionnelles vous voyez tout ça
c'était très
très ambigu très difficile à gérer et
puis une fois que c'est parti dans les
médias vous pouvez pas non plus être le
patron conservateur enfin vous n'avez
pas le droit à l'explication on n'avait
pas le temps de l'explication donc en
fait il se trouve que chez nous ça s'est
assez bien passé que peut-être à part
une dizaine ou une quinzaine de magasins
qui ont particulièrement souffert parce
qu'ils étaient trop loin de la ville
étaient fermées etc
dans l'ensemble on a pu satisfaire sous
forme de primes ou ou de contrat
d'intéressement cesser ces propositions
mais vous pouvez voir que cette année
l'offre a été réitéré par le président
de la république et monsieur castex et
ça ne n'attire plus les foules enfin je
veux dire
bien sûr tout salarié est très content
de recevoir une prime mais aujourd'hui
vraiment cette prime est là quelque
chose d'éphémère de très politique aussi
on voit bien que cette politique qui ne
le prend pas dans son budget qui demande
aux entreprises de les refiler et nous
on préfère à ce moment là dans la
discussion entre partenaires sociaux
partager à tout le monde le fruit de
l'entreprise très difficile de faire de
la discrimination est finalement en fait
on ne risquait pas sa vie en venant
travailler il n'y a pas de kloster enfin
je n'ai pas eu de remontée de maladies
decaux vide en groupe dans la
distribution c'est d'ailleurs un
paradoxe c'est c'est je crois que roux
de bézieux le patron du medef le
rappelait avant-hier soir les classes
les plus gros kloster ont eu lieu en
famille en fait c'est dans la vie privée
ou mais en magasin avec les gestes de
distanciation qui ont été matérialisés
dans les magasins malgré de temps en
temps quelques mouvements de foule les
protection en plexiglas et il a fallu
trouver des pleins d'artisans pour
monter des dd plexi partout et non je
n'ai pas connaissance qu'il ya eu dans
la distribution de clusters dans les
abattoirs il ya eu dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire on va faire une pause
michel edouard leclerc on se retrouve
juste après on va voir ce qui a vraiment
changé dans la consommation
avec le coronavirus
[Musique]
nous sommes donc avec michel edouard
leclerc qui publient avec alexandre tu à
lyon les essentiels de la république
comment lakovic 19 à changes et la
consommation des français c'est un peu
son son journal de bord depuis depuis un
an maintenant je crois que dans tous les
souvenirs qu'on gardera de cette crise
du corps à des virus y aura votre tweet
il ya un tweet de vous j'ai déjà placé
dans cette émission mais qui à l'époque
avait fait beaucoup rire les français
c'est c'est le tweet dans lequel vous
faisiez les différences entre les
produits essentiels et les produits
qu'ils n'étaient pas certains ont pu le
prendre meilleure au premier degré mais
quand on le disait en voyait bien que
c'était pour rire ou du mot pour vous
moquer du gouvernement on était en
absurdistan 1
c'est là on est au 2e confinement c'est
le moment où tout à coup on referme les
magasins on n'obtient que
la grande distribution ferme les rayons
qui correspondent au magasin fermé de
façon à pas le faire une fausse
concurrence
enfin une mauvaise concurrence plus
exactement une concurrence injuste et
puis on fait le tri à l'intérieur entre
les biens essentiels les biens non
essentiels et ça m'a donné ce tweet vous
saviez en l'écrivant que vous alliez
obtenir de telles réactions
en fait c'est quand je fais ça c'est je
je je donne droit à la colère de nos
salariés qui avait bien respecté toutes
les mesures sanitaires et qui ne
comprennent pas qu'on leur fait face m
des plastiques dans certaines parties du
magasin en plus où c'est toutes ces
listes administrative
elle met des produits par catégorie
juridique par taille et ça ça correspond
absolument pas à leur emplacement dans
un magasin donc il faut non seulement
défaire les rayons les refaire les
plastifiée des enrubanné va c'est chiant
quoi et donc on se pose la question
qu'est ce que ça a à voir avec le
sanitaire avec la protection et de fête
et de fait même mois sur le coup je ne
ne mesure pas que cette décision
administrative va avoir un impact
extrêmement démobilisateur sur les
commerçants sur nos salariés bien avant
d'abord que qu'on confonde produits
essentiels et commerçant essentiel
là on est tout simplement sur une
réponse politique du premier ministre à
une opposition qui commence à faire dole
à des commerçants
pour faire des arrêtés municipaux et les
autoriser et résister à au droit de
l'état quoi il ya pas mal d'arrêtés
municipaux qui sont pris il ya une
certaine collusion entre des fédérations
de commerçants et l'union des maires de
france qui est pas plus qu est pas trés
lrm est donc laissée arrêtés municipaux
font ouvrir des magasins permettent
d'ouvrir des magasins alors que le
premier ministre dans le plan sanitaire
les avait fait fermer et donc le premier
ministre en fait est un cette montée
poujadiste le risque gilet jaune east
dans le commerce en demandant une grotte
aux grandes surfaces de fermer une
partie de leurs rayons
toi tu es fermé parce que tu es un
commerçant spécialisé donc je demande à
leclerc à carrefour et aux autres de
faire mais aussi dans leurs rayons quand
bien même tout ça était bien organisé
alors en tant que chef d'entreprise
la politique a ses droits je la gestion
d'une crise sanitaire
je reconnais que c'est aussi une gestion
sociale de la crise sanitaire et les
patrons des grandes enseignes n'ont pas
trop réagi mais nos salariés l'ont pas
compris et c'était ça le sens de mon
tweet l'avre le coup le gouvernement a
péché par manque de communication quoi
et par manque d'anticipation aussi parce
qu'après tout on pouvait s'y attendre à
être obligés d'être confiné en octobre
visiblement personne n'avait prévu le
coup et qui se retrouvent en improvisant
à commettre des injustices ou en tout
cas ce qui est perçu comme tel par les
français et les français aiment beaucoup
d'égalité donc quand tout le monde est
fermé ça va mais si on a un qui est
ouvert et pas l'autre ça commence à
devenir un problème
et c'était vrai la fin les pyjamas deux
ans on avait le droit de les vendre et
des pyjamas trois ans on n'avait pas le
droit
ceci ouais et c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui
c'était un gros party dans cette
segmentation et ceci dit vous voyez pour
pour pour vous montrer aussi que tout ça
est purement politique voire
corporatiste
nos copains libraire ketef qui avait
demandé à ne pas ouvrir pendant le
premier confinement ont voulu ouvrir au
deuxième et on les a aidés à ouvrir et
donc et bruno le maire je les ai vus a
plaidé pour que les libraires ouvre mais
aujourd'hui les fnac les culturales et
les furet du nord sont quand ils sont
dans les grands centres commerciaux sont
fermés les libraires de ses dents
enseigne la sont fermées donc l'équité
c'est une équité conçue très politique
c'est du fait du faible au fort enfin
c'est c'est mais bon disons les choses
très clairement ça se passe pas trop mal
en france quand même de ce point de vue
là franchement tout le monde a
ras-le-bol de ces allers retours de ce
confinement mais en même temps je pour
avoir des alliés des coopérateurs en
italie en allemagne en belgique on n'est
pas les plus mal lotis un oral plus mais
on n'est pas les plus mal lotis on se
souvient alors ça c'était plutôt pour un
premier confinement on a dit que vous
aviez vendu moins de maquillage - de
déodorant et on en avait conclu que les
français se négliger ouais ouais joue il
y avait des stocks
peut-être aussi mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut pas il faut pas prendre la
consommation qui s'est passé pendant le
premier et deuxième confinement comme
une tendance
c'est une grande parenthèse dans une
tendance plus générale plus vertueuse on
a retrouvé sa désormais la crise
sanitaire a rajouté cette préoccupation
sanitaire dans la demande de du mieux
manger du mieux-être
on a il ya une philosophie du corps on
voit ça dans toutes les revues par
exemple aujourd'hui dans les kiosques à
journaux sur les 110 j talent toutes les
tout là tout ce qui concerne le mieux
manger le mieux-être le sport chez soi
le yoga intègre une demande sociale qui
s'exprime pour tous les comportements et
sa maintenance est un acquis et que ça
vient renforcer ce qu'on appelait les
états généraux de l'alimentation il ya 4
5 ans c'est à dire cette narration
collective
d'un nouveau modèle alimentaire français
- bonne bouffe traditionnelle classique
et plus plus vertueuse sur le plan
sanitaire
ça c'est justement vers lequel on va
maintenant qui s'accélère justement là
c'est vrai que on achète moins de
maquillage à partir du moment où on sort
moins et qu'on va pas travailler qu on
reste chez soi derrière son ordinateur
mais ce qui avait frappé c'était le
moins de déodorant alors vous dites
qu'au même moment vous avez vendu
beaucoup plus de savon par exemple donc
ça va dans ce sens là c'est à dire que
c'était plus écolo au fond et puis c'est
plus pour sa propreté pour soi que pour
que pour l'impression que ça peut donner
aux autres au fil au fond c'est pour ça
qu'on préfère le savon au dos rond ouais
je pense que désormais dans la société
française la préoccupation hygiéniste
elle est forte
je vous rappelle que on était un peuple
qu'il ya un an se moquer de tout
asiatiques qui arrivait dans province ou
visiter le mont saint michel odent même
dans les grands espaces et qui est qu'il
ne quittait pas leurs masques
aujourd'hui malgré des mouvements anti
masque personne ne rentre dans un
magasin sans mettre un masque
il n'y a pas d'actes d'incivilité les
antilles masque on s'exprime peut-être
sur les réseaux sociaux mais dans leur
pratique
voilà là je pense que la crise à cette
crise du coc vide cette pandémie a fait
faire aux français un bond dans
l'appréciation de de leur hygiène de
leur hygiène
s agissant de l'esthétique la parfumerie
mais de leur hygiène bien sûr
alimentaire il ya eu là la bataille pour
les sapins de noël au monde noël vous
pouvez nous raconter comment vous l'avez
vécu vous c'est vrai que vous avez cités
bon collaborateur éric alexandre tu à
lyon qui a cosigné ce livre il sait que
je tiens un journal de bord il a piqué
dedans il a regardé tous les jours il y
avait un truc ça méritait pas en soi de
faire un livre mais l'addition de tout
ça montre la réalité de ce qu'ils ont
fait que que la france marche quoi il y
avait rappelez vous c'était le muguet le
muguet du 1er mai moi j'ai insisté
à des trucs dingues quoi avec le lobby
des fleuristes qui dit on va quand même
pas mettre tout ça à la belle y avait
des tulipes au sli on va tous on va
quand même pas mettre tout ça à la benne
alors il y avait des discussions de
savoir s'il étudie péter française qui
distribuait le muguet tout ça alors le
premier ministre en cheval et hop
pas de fleurs didier guillaume ministre
de l'agriculture intervient demande
l'arbitrage de bruno le maire est dit
c'est quand même des gens c'est quand
même dehors ça m'emmerde personne
finalement vous savez à quoi on aboutit
à l'autorisation de vente des fleurs
dans les grandes surfaces chez carrefour
chez leclerc et même peut-être au rayon
de leroy merlin et à condition d'en pas
en faire la publicité
voilà c'est ça que convie quoi donc un
dialogue un dialogue mais totalement
absurde entre entre 7,6 du bourget ce
c'est entre une administration qui suit
une une ligne et puis des professionnels
qui sont là en train de dire ça va
tomber par la gauche ça va venir de la
droite et et on a vécu comme ça pendant
un an et on continue de le vivre comme
ça et et tout ça en plus avec le soupçon
que ça profite à amazon et ou e-commerce
mais surtout à amazon ça devenait un peu
on a même dit à un moment vous le
rappeler que jean castex n'était le
meilleur employé du mois d' amazon
ouais d'ailleurs j'ai eu un problème
parce qu'on va il m'a attribué le
l'origine de noms je n'avais pas eu ce
talent ans je sais pas dans quel magasin
des salariés avait écrit ça ou des
commerçants avaient réécrit ça dans la
réalité c'est vrai que tout le monde
était encadrée sauf amazon c'est dans la
réalité aussi
c'est un constat que tout commerçant
aujourd'hui il peut pas simplement
prendre un bain zone comme épouvantail
désormais amazon c'est comme il dit la
voix il dit la voix du digital il dit la
voix du clic et collecte et on a vu
effectivement que même les restaurateurs
aujourd'hui offrent des places sur des
plateformes digitales que ce soit des
libéraux ou même des plateformes de
centres leclerc ou de carrefour
ou de monoprix donc en fait la crise a
terriblement accélérer la digitalisation
de l'économie dans la relation avec les
clients par exemple
et puis tout le web commerce quoi qui a
explosé comme comme on pouvait pas
l'anticiper il faut savoir que la jeu
l'année dernière les centres leclerc ont
eu un million de clients supplémentaires
venus par le drive
donc c'est nous avons eu la
fréquentation sur le drive qu'on
anticipait pour dans quatre ans donc ça
incroyable c'est à la fois pour des
raisons sanitaires c'est aussi parce que
le drive permet de comparer les prix
avant de prendre sa voiture et d'aller
chercher puis maintenant il ya toutes
sortes de deux drives piétons c'est un
peu une ineptie sur le plan du langage
mais en tout cas il ya beaucoup de
relais piétons qui tous les groupes de
distribution deviennent multicanal votre
avis ça va rester ça à la fois les
commerces le click and collect le drive
piétons oui ça ça va rester écoutez
c'était quand même drôle
il ya eu une association entier amazon
d'écrivains qui disait qu'il fallait
plus aller acheter des livres chez
amazon tandis que les libraires étaient
fermés mais ils se rendent même pas
compte que c'était leur livre qui était
aussi sur amazon donc tout ça était à la
fois un peu c'était gentil au départ ça
se voulait soutien aux libraires mais en
même temps tout ça était assez hypocrite
par rapport à l'avenir parce que pour
les éditeurs évidemment amazon
aujourd'hui c'est le client numéro un
donc si tel est le cas c'est amazon ça
doit venir de nous devons le challenge
et nous devons relever ce défi il suffit
pas de le désigner comme bouc émissaire
comme d'autres ont désigné les
hypermarchés autrefois face aux petits
commerces il s'agit maintenant de
prendre le d'apprendre le digital et
d'aller là où les consommateurs ou les
clients ou les lecteurs ont envie
d'aller quoi tout la télévision n'a pas
n'a pas interdit la radio et
et le cinéma même si aujourd'hui les
cinémas sans fer mais heureusement il ya
la télévision quoi c'est on va vers
l'ubiquité du consommateur et des modes
de distribution multicanaux multicanal
le petit commerce de proximité a repris
presque je dirais du poil de la bête
mais j'irai en terme d'image de
d'importance au fond pour les français
vous avez c'est un sentiment également
ouais ouais la proximité est
certainement une des gagnantes un des
concepts gagnants de cette crise après
je suis perplexe parce que je sais pas
s'il faut parler de proximité ou
d'accessibilité
parce que quand vous avez c'était la
photo du début quand vous avez un
un cycliste et demain un robot qui vous
amène votre plat elle est sur une liste
de menus extraordinaire et que vous
pouvez les avoir en un quart d'heure en
20 minutes en une heure je sais pas si
c'est vraiment la proximité qu'ils
gagnent ou cette libre accès quoi
j'aurais plutôt tendance à dire à des
jeunes qui veulent monter leur
entreprise aujourd'hui de ne pas acheter
trop cher les fonds de commerce même
proche des quartiers est plutôt de
choisir ceux qui sont accessibles ce que
c'est l'accessibilité le maître mot la
relocalisation de la production on en a
beaucoup parlé vous même vous y avez été
confronté vous le disiez tout à l'heure
à partir du moment où on pouvait plus
acheter des produits agricoles des
produits de consommation à l'étranger on
a dû
tout mettre sur la production de
française est-ce que c'est fait pour
durer votre avis alors il ya un vrai
c'est une vraie évolution qui en
politique peut se traduire par des mots
comme patriotti souverainisme il ya
plusieurs déclinaisons possibles mais il
ya la conscience de la fragilité de
n'être couvert au monde et pas être
assez fort chez soi en fait dans la
réaction de bruno le maire par exemple à
la tentative de rachat d'une partie des
actions de carrefour
c'était peut-être excessive dans dans la
forme mais tout le monde découvrait
qu'au fond les grandes entités
économiques du monde s'appuie sur une
distribution maîtrisée les grands de la
high tech aux états unis savent qu'ils
ont un marché en plus monolingue oil
acquis quoi les chinois reconquiert les
alibaba mêmes ont refoulé les auchan et
les carrefours en inde aucune de nos
grandes enseignes internationales
n'arrive à pénétrer et on voit bien même
en amérique latine que si carrefour et
casino sont encore des traits dominants
on voit bien aussi que y'a pas remettre
de procès qui leur sont fait d'être venu
d'ailleurs donc je crois que à la fois
sur le plan géopolitique et sur le plan
de la consommation on a conscience de la
nécessité de défendre un marché
intérieur
et oui les consommateurs privilégient
sur les étiquettes
alors à condition que ce soit pas trop
cher mais il privilégie le made in
france le made in bretagne
c'est sûr qu'il ya une et c'est bon pour
nos agriculteurs pour le coup parce que
là il ya si ce n'est un argumentaire
économique il ya une émotion un
sentiment qui justifie l'achat
privilégier les produits français
quand on regarde ça va rester quand on
regarde à l'échelle de l'histoire depuis
200 ans
les prix n'ont jamais cessé de baisser
c'est à la fois du la révolution
industrielle une révolution technique
une révolution de la distribution une
révolution des transports
une révolution économique aussi qu'on a
appelé la main
réalisation donc révolution des échanges
tout ça fait que depuis deux cents ans
les prix baissent est ce qui pourrait
arrêter baissé à votre avis alors je
pense que beaucoup de gens pensent comme
ce que vous venez dénoncer mais je pense
que ce n'est pas vrai c'est à dire que
il ya tout produit nouveau mis sur le
marché voit sa courbe de prix décroître
au fur et à mesure qu'ils s'amortit
qu'il se développe mais il se crée
beaucoup de services et beaucoup de
produits nouveaux qui viennent renchérir
le pouvoir d'achat des gens est en fait
le coût de la vie est plus élevé malgré
la baisse des prix vous voyez c'est à
dire que c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup le poste de télévision l'écran
sont pris à / 15 par 20 mai en même
temps le prix d'un iphone augmente la
technologie incluse dedans fait un arc
créer un argumentaire qui fait que
l'abonnement coûte plus cher que la
coque etc
je pense qu'il ya une double mécanique
qui fait qu'il ya des prix qui
décroissent mais il ya toujours de
nouvelles offres qui font que au total
le panier et eicher et alors
dans ces périodes de crise ça on le voit
bien parce que ça s'appelle la précarité
on voit bien que là il ya des moments où
ça cale au niveau des ménages vous voyez
on a on a dit les français ont d'épargné
ils n'ont pas dépensé
non ça c'est des plus riches qui ont mis
200 milliards de côté qui sont pas
partis en voyage mais jamais je n'ai vu
de ma vie
autant de précarité ça se traduit par le
fait que justement
l'alimentation est acheté chichement ça
se traduit par des préoccupations dans
les étudiants par exemple qui sont tout
seuls dans leur ville un peu à l'abandon
en télétravail etc
au niveau de l'hygiène au niveau des
repas ça explique la prise de position
du président de la république était très
symbolique de 1 euro un repas au crous à
l'université ce que nous avons fait en
magasin aussi en en assemblant des
magnifiques
enfin des menus vrai mais un euro je
pense que la précarité
aujourd'hui et vécu en france de manière
très révoltante
elle est presque prêt révolutionnaire
jeu aujourd'hui elle est résignée parce
que parce qu'il ya rien à côté quoi il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de locaux vides
nous oblige à vivre comme ça mais que ce
soit la précarité d'hygiène pour les
femmes que ce soit la précarité pour
manger que ce soit pour se déplacer les
transports on s'en rend pas compte mais
jamais vu ça en france encore jamais vu
et quand même j'ai 40 ans de vie
professionnelle j'ai connu de crise
pétrolière j'ai connu des crises
sanitaires
là je ressens véritablement quand je
vais dans les magasins je vois les gens
qui qui demandent quoi qu'ils demandent
et d'ailleurs les associations comme les
banques alimentaires ou sons sont
dépassés mais quand je disais que les
prix n'avaient cessé de baisser je veux
dire par là que à vélo plutôt une moto
aujourd'hui est vendu le prix d'un vélo
autrefois c'est à dire que tous les prix
ont baissé vous avez tout à fait raison
l'offre est devenue beaucoup plus riche
donc ça permet aussi de d'augmenter le
téléphone portable c'est pas le
téléphone en bakélite qu'on avait relié
à un fil et forcément tout est plus cher
parce que c'est un téléphone portable et
que dans ce téléphone portable il ya une
telle est une radio un ordinateur etc
c'est donc évidemment ça démultiplie son
prix mais mais le téléphone en bakélite
si on continuait de l'acheter il serait
moins cher qu'on ne le paient autrefois
ce que je veux dire c'est que
aujourd'hui parce que le commerce
international est ce qu'il est et que
nous ne sommes toujours pas sortis du
coc vis de nous en france
est ce qu'il y aurait un risque que par
hasard si on renonce tous les leviers de
la mondialisation qui ont fait beaucoup
pour faire baisser les prix
quoi qu'on en dise est ce qu il se
pourrait que tout à coup bien le vélo
la moto ça redevienne plus cher mais
aussi les tomates et les petits pois
ouais mais c'est là où le système
capitaliste on parle d'intelligence
artificielle mais ce sont des personnes
et des intérêts qui sont derrière le
système capitaliste en train d'accélérer
le processus de destruction créatrice
pourquoi le prix des bagnoles d'essence
et que votre valeur de revente de
voitures mérite pas que conte la vende
plus cher parce que les nouvelles
voitures qui arrivent n'auront rien à
voir avec la voiture que vous aviez et
en plus la réglementation vous empêchera
vous empêchera de rouler avec votre
vieille bagnole d'occasion vous pourrez
pas mettre de diesel etc et donc vous
voyez c'est je pense pas qu'il y aura
une remontée du prix des vélos mais les
motos les vélos vont devenir électriques
vont être beaucoup plus cher on passe de
produits qui était à 1 200 400 euros
aujourd'hui à des produits qui sont
au-delà de 1000 euros le capital
renouvelle son offre jeudi le
capitalisme comme si j'étais un
mélenchon mais c'est une réalité quoi le
le le il ya toujours une offre qui
serait qui se renouvelle je sais pas
jusqu'à quand je ne crois pas à la
croissance infinie
je ne suis pas un adepte je peins
ultralibéral je ne crois pas à la
croissance infinie mais force est de
constater aujourd'hui que par exemple
tout le plan de relance aux etats-unis
comme en europe va aller sur les
énergies nouvelles
donc sur les nouvelles voitures sur les
nouveaux avions tête à hydrogène
jusqu'en 2050 et donc on va nous faire
changer tous les équipements tout la
domotique
donc c'est aussi un marché qui s'ouvrent
colossal colossal donc je crois que nos
vieilles bécanes elles serviront plus à
grand chose quoi nos vieilles
imprimantes
donc les filles auront bombay au robot
baisser ils remonteront pas non et ils
briques site qu'est ce que ça a changé
pour vous le brésil en tant que breton
c'est que ça nous a piqué des zones de
pêche
voilà en tout cas donc il faut changer
non mais pour être concret ça veut dire
que les pêcheurs de normands bretons ont
devant eux et les boulonnais on
je pars à 4-5 ans devant eux mais il va
falloir aller chercher de nouvelles
espèces pour se substituer aux espèces
que qu'on achète quoi il va falloir ou
alors renégocier avec les anglais
quelque chose mais les anglais sont pas
mauvaise et on nous a fait deux fois le
coût que le break site allait couler la
grande bretagne et ensuite que son
isolement sur le plan géopolitique
allait encore faire la guerre entre
l'irlande l'écossé
regardons cette histoire et il nous
donne des leçons sur le plan de la
politique de la santé de la vaccination
c'est incroyable ce que ce que cette
crise ravaler carte je parlais
d'approvisionnement là on a vu que on
avait prédit qu'avec le break 6 qui
auraient des pénuries alimentaires en
grande bretagne la seule pénurie qu'on a
vu c'est en france dans un certain
nombre de supermarchés anglais tout à
coup on ne trouvait plus des produits
qui venait d'angleterre et qui ne
pouvaient plus parvenir jusque là mais
ça c'était à cause du bric site s'était
pas à cause alors est ce qui est des
produits qu'on a perdus ou que vous avez
perdu qu'il faut remplacer par des
produits européens par non non non non
faudrait que l'angleterre n'est pas une
grande puissance agroalimentaire on a
perdu certainement des moteurs de
voitures des harley davidson et des
trucs comme ça
mais même aujourd'hui la grande bretagne
l'export peu plus ses disques et donc on
les enregistre
non ça ne fait pas outre mesure la crise
du covin bon pour l'instant est toujours
là il y à la ddt à l'horizon ce sera la
dernière question vous voyez l'avenir
proche comment michel edouard leclerc en
tant que patron de la grande
distribution
moi je suis je suis optimiste parce que
on a vu plein de gens
depuis trois ans quatre ans réclamé des
plans marshall pour sortir de la crise
puisque là il ya la crise due qu'au bout
d'un an on était de rentrer dans une
crise économique précédemment et en fait
si vous additionnez tous les plans de
relance celui de joe biden aux états
unis colossal celui de l'europe celui du
japon dont on parle peu dans tous les
pays du sud est asiatique
c'est colossal et les chinois avec leur
projet de route de la soie
c'est dix fois le plan marshall kiki et
qui est en jeu quoi donc ça fait
énormément d'offres qui vont arriver sur
le marché l'économie
je pense normalement devrait ressortir
très très vite duras et l'état français
n'a n'a pas failli et enfin je sais bien
que personne n'a financé tout ça et que
ça reste de lait de l'argent magique
mais mais pour le moment du chauffeur de
taxi au patron d'une charcuterie enfin
il ya du soutien en tout cas ça doit
être matérialisée milhas du soutien au
moi je suis optimiste mais surtout ce
que j'ai voulu écrire dans ce petit
bouquin dans le titre des essentiels de
la république c'est que justement il
faut pas faire pour le plan de relance
les mêmes erreurs que pour le plan de
confinement c'est vraiment il faut
fédérer l'ensemble des français ne pas
les diviser les mettre là où ils sont
dans cette perspective en commun ce
n'est qu'à cette condition là que la
france va se redresser
parce que si on est parti pour les
chamailleries corporatistes et si on le
divise les français pour des raisons
politiques politiciennes alors là on va
louper le coche
ouais donc mon message il est quand même
très politique j'ai vu fonctionner j'ai
vécu une époque où madame lambert m'a
appelé le soir madame lambert président
de la fnsea ja happ et le soir pour
travailler à la vente du veau français
ou ou de l'agneau de pâques etc
cette solidarité même très courte même
très faible cette solidarité est là il
faut il faut la garder parce que on est
tous est essentielle
on est tous des rouages de quelque chose
qui nous dépasse et c'est ce qui nous
dépasse qui fait qu' on va s'en sortir
mais c'est parce qu'un discours
politique non si michel edouard leclerc
les essentiels de la république c'est le
titre de ce livre co écrit avec
alexandre tu es lyon qui vient de
paraître aux éditions de l'observatoire
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]